depuis lundi ces ambulanciers
paramédicaux font plus qu amener les
patients aux portes de l'urgence
qui l'on file désormais l'équipement de
protection des infirmières pour faire
une partie de leur travail c'est pour ça
qu'on est là c'est pour prêter main
forte aux infirmières on le sait que les
infirmières sont épuisés je vous
installez le brassard pour la pression
ces ambulanciers paramédicaux prennent
les signes vitaux mesure la glycémie ou
installent l'oxygène le travail
essentiel des tâches au moins pour les
employés de l'urgence ça donne des bras
de plus puis là on est d'autant les
infirmières qui proposait parce que tout
ce qui est habillement tout ce qui est
jaquette est souvent la préposée qui le
fait donc on vient aider plusieurs
sphères de l'urgence
une quinzaine de paramédicaux ont suivi
la formation pour travailler à l'urgence
une idée du sis de montérégie centre
pour éliminer le fameux temps
supplémentaire obligatoire
dans l'urgence était c'est pas une
option il n'y a pas de ts aux attentes
aux gens c'est pas notre façon de
procéder nous on a décidé de se
réorganiser les paramédics y
travailleront donc avec les infirmières
à l'urgence au moins jusqu'au mois de
décembre
au niveau des médecins aussi ont tout
réorganiser certaines tâches pour
justement aussi enlevé la charge de
travail des infirmières chacun a
vraiment donné lors 200% pour dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire justement
pour réduire la surcharge de travail
tous et paramédics souhaite ainsi
prouver qu'ils peuvent élargir leur rôle
dans le réseau de la santé on est
polyvalent et puis on veut le démontrer
qu'on est polyvalent deux autres
établissements de la région de montréal
vont aussi faire appel à des
ambulanciers paramédicaux pour appuyer
les infirmières des urgences
épuisée par 18 mois de pandémie ici
david gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal